[Music]
how many of you guys have an alexa
it's an echo you have an echo well it's
called an echo and then you say
alex but then like you don't you like
alexa set a timer for 12 minutes
i just made everyone's time you know
what i'd be [ __ ] hating my little
google home right now
my google home got a little [ __ ]
attitude so this morning oh he does have
an attitude
i don't like him last night yeah mine's
a girl i'm setting my alarm
mine's a hurt too because i haven't set
my alarm in ages i have no reason to
wake up
so whoever jk that's depressing yeah
that's very sad
at a certain time i want so you have a
reason to live dude i'm just gonna
go ahead do i no you don't i'm just
kidding set the timer and i go
hey google set an alarm for 9 30 am she
goes 9 30 am it said
a.m next time if you want to try doing
the alarm why don't you say like i was
like [ __ ] excuse me yes
yeah [ __ ] give me a sec you [ __ ]
just do it wow also
my alexa when i go um alexa what's the
temperature outside she goes the
temperature outside
is 73 degrees when i ask my google home
because alex is downstairs google holds
upstairs but i'm like what's the
temperature outside
he goes 73. really
you know what i'm saying he's not he's
not polite
he's rude no bedside matters you know
what else i have with your apple watch
uh because i i do the like the exercise
tracking and all that [ __ ] and then
it'll tell you
it's like huh you've actually gone a lot
further other times
yeah i don't [ __ ] [ __ ] with things
like that because i don't want my
feelings hurt
usually you're much further by this time
you guys playing with fire man that's
just dangerous google home is mean
i know yeah so we have a google upstairs
and then we have the studio
the home apple homepod downstairs and
siri doesn't know
[ __ ] ever she's [ __ ] stupid so she
doesn't belong in the house she
literally
does not know anything what's the
question that you ask and she's like
like something simple like the
temperature she's like i'm sorry i
cannot help you with that right now i'm
like what the [ __ ] can you do
you guys have big accents [ __ ] casey
is
the captain he's acting what's the
weather guy
can you tell me how like a hot in it
it's a hard call tell me just tell me
i'm sorry i don't understand that but
then mix that with texan because he's
from texas
yeah what'd that sound like what'd that
sound like see
what'd that sound like she's like i'm
sorry i don't understand
either hot outside y'all maybe not
[Laughter]
maybe it is our accents because our
freaking trash can is voice activated
too so it'd be like open can
and it never what did you just say why
did you have a voice
activated trash can that is the laziest
thing i've ever heard in my life
shout out to wong fu because they gave
it to us it was like a gift because we
they did a brand deal with a simple
human you know what's dope about wong fu
you could say [ __ ] wong fu and they'll
never say it back they don't say f words
[ __ ] you wong fu [ __ ] wong fu go to go
to bo
po mo po cafe yeah that's why i have the
trash can they gifted it to us
but um so yeah dude another thing
so alexa i'm like alexa play lana del
rey she goes okay she plays the lawn del
rey
upstairs i'm like hey google play lana
del rey he goes
that artist is only available for
subscribers however there's a
station you might like that has lana del
rey
music on it just playing you [ __ ] i'm
like the problem if you have spotify
link it to the google he won't tell you
that i'm not doing [ __ ] with that guy
well then you're gonna keep getting
attitude girl
[ __ ] google home's problem is they too
much explanation yeah
do it or not just [ __ ] [ __ ] pizza get
off the pot like well tell me other ways
to do it i don't care
i like my google you use google yeah
but google never plays the right size so
it's all together we're playing that
song game
and then we're just sitting naming songs
and it was naming all these [ __ ] i'm
judging you for liking google i played
this one song it was like supposed to be
like a song game like a like a gangster
rap and they started playing some reggae
version of that
and i'm like what the [ __ ] hey google
play boys to men ain't nothing but a
gangster
i hit your perfect i used joe alexa
alexa
turn number five okay i got it
i got it
the reason why i bring up alexa here is
because
this woman from london she hacked into
her
ex-boyfriend's amazon electrical device
and she used it to scare off his new
girlfriend oh that's lame
from 130 miles away long distance
relationship huh
so they have that's dedication yeah no i
think might be that good
really really jealous so her name is
felipe
philippa and she's 45 years old come on
[ __ ] old lady no they have nothing to
do
they're like the kids are gone the kids
are gone i'm not dating i'm not getting
dizzy you become more pity when you're
older
and lonely i like those classes if you
haven't found purpose yet
that's really sad purpose-driven wife
yes
christian joke because a purpose-driven
life is like a good book that went
really viral in the
christian community oh i tried giving it
to somebody and he threw it in the
garbage can once
i went to his church never read the book
though oh he threw it away
thanks man i really appreciate it alexa
throw this book away
i didn't do it it was telexa i'm sorry
okay so what ended up happening here is
that they were in a relationship for two
years
and he ended the relationship and then
he ended up
having a new fling a new sweetie and
then that's when
she ended up hacking into his alexa
account because as long as you have the
pin or whatever like apparently she had
already had access to his alexa
from the relationship probably i didn't
even know you couldn't log in somewhere
yeah i just talked to it yeah no yeah so
from that you set it up
uh you just yeah i plugged it in the
wall oh oh maybe that's why it doesn't
work for you
no it no alexa works great just but i
didn't know you could log in somewhere
you could do the same thing with google
home and you can connect i know he told
me that and i was like no
no we're not doing this just do what i
tell you honestly the app
sucks ass it does never [ __ ] works
anyway you could ask alexa it'll take
you probably an hour and 30 minutes
alexa set up my alexa
i like it all right [ __ ]
i wish my [ __ ] would say all right [ __ ]
you bug i'll do it
it's a rude option or something yeah i
love it talk to me [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that one restaurant that calls you
a [ __ ] an [ __ ] and all these things
okay but what she was doing though is
she was turning on and off the lights
in the home oh that's scary and she was
telling like like screaming at the
girlfriend to pack her [ __ ] and leave
get the [ __ ] out of here you [ __ ] take
your stuff and
leave and so the make like a chia leaf
make like a banana and split
which makes you think i'm like did she
try to sound like alexa
like when she was doing it [ __ ] hurry
up and leave
and so the girlfriend she was so
distressed that she ended up
leaving and crying why don't you unplug
that [ __ ]
exactly it's a very simple solution you
dumb idiot dude
it's like uh just do this
yeah well i don't know i guess this guy
had like a really
smart home because if the lights are
connected yeah the light bulb could be
uh
it might be built into the house with
the speakers up there she should have
done
like if if a regular ass voice was
yelling at me to pack my stuff i'm like
this is some stupid yeah she's kind of
dumb unless she like
talked like a demon and was like
flickering the lights and was like get
out
get it i'd be like i'm gone that's scary
i like how you'd run away like a cartoon
it's just her legs moving little circle
legs get the branding's off
i never i never get scared of a british
ghost hello
hello hello hello get out of the house
but yeah and so not only did she do that
but she also
hacked her ex's facebook account and
uploaded
nude photos of oh she going to jail
oh she could go to jail easy for that
well she did make bail
and so uh she was because she should be
arrested she was released on bail on the
condition that she does not contact her
ex and is due to appear in court
next month isn't that like a harassment
yeah she she was uh but
she's like it was the ghost not me she
didn't do a ghost voice
how can you be so obsessed with a in an
individual like that that blows my
[ __ ]
ego some people can't let things go oh
no they're just stuck in their teddy
walk teddy wap
i've never been that way and i've never
had anyone be that way with me probably
npd yeah i mean to like define your
happiness into one individual that much
because they don't have happiness inside
that's why
that's a bomb ass lyric though girl you
write music or something reading books
and writing literacy [ __ ] well yeah
because you don't have inside happiness
[Music]
alexa turn the song off oh [ __ ]
i don't understand that oh [ __ ] we don't
want joe alexa they're going to do
whatever they want alexa off
they're continuing alexa
louder it's like the christmas present
you didn't ask for it
so sad your paper was on sale
because she's empty inside she doesn't
have love inside or some [ __ ]
i don't know that [ __ ] is empty
you know what writing music is [ __ ]
difficult man like you have to be in a
very specific mind state to write
certainly it's hard
that's why i had inspiration but y'all
try to shut me down and [ __ ] damn
not you no one tried to do that to you
it was just alexa oh that's true that's
true that's true
i was joe alexa talking joe don't care
dude when you said that it gave me a
flashback of the song that i wrote when
i was a kid
you gotta say it right now you gotta say
it right now yo i got your background
right now
wait dude i just remember the first part
which was like
uh i was walking home from school my
friends and me we were having a good
time
isaac was singing making up a song oh
yeah his song was dumb so we were at an
airbnb
and you could she has blink set up or
nest or whatever
um that she could see isaac singing a
song oh he's home alone
and he has the cats and he's like casey
want to go get some groceries that's why
he's alone
he's like i'm home alone it's just me
and my
two and so is though
um all alone and uh yeah it was some
[ __ ] like that but like even like the
flow was so good and he like made it
rhyme too where i was like that's
beautiful and then
so i ended up scaring him because i
turned on the voice thingy
and then i was like that's a good song i
was like isaac you're not alone i'm
with you and he goes and then he ran he
looks at the camera
and then he [ __ ] wrote man you ruined
his vibe that was his moment
but that was just too [ __ ] cute i'm
not in the studio mom
he's like oh this is my studio time
actually save the clip i'll show you
guys
but now he's never gonna make music oh
she's gonna be all scared of cameras and
[ __ ]
he's always always always singing and
he's always like coming up with some
lyrics and i'm like dude you're so good
you should write something
he should i used to write rap songs he
should make an album
i i don't want to hear about that uh we
don't want to hear about that
i know what the loyal from brooklyn
nine-nine
no what was it do you remember any of
them it's eminem stop i only remember
it's a trap tiff
no it's a trap i don't i need to hear
the lyrics right now
i heard yours and i want to hear you you
want to hear my rap i do not say
spaghetti or anything like that
from when i was 15 oh this is about to
be emo let's hear this [ __ ]
i don't know if i can remember it i
remember some okay hold on
it goes i put time into rhyme and
insight and violence when i erupt
corrupt and vacuum seas with the touch
of a button disrupting wanna be thugs
and cutting them up into nothing
interrupting their fun
just to get a reaction my style's packed
with satisfaction like a weakness in my
rapid cause factors i'll attack you with
a verbal overdose of skill my rhymes are
so verbose and it'll leave you aching
with pain and staking your veins
wouldn't hurt as much as a dope nose i
spill but you can cope with it till i
bust out with the freshness you better
sebastian can't mess with this
aggressive perfection i'll paralyze you
through metal protection with a mental
injection your best bet is to step son
melted like butter looking for a better
escape route cause you know you ain't
safe now but stay around what you gonna
do can't stop this incredible inevitable
flow and i'm throwing at you you know
when it's true the crowd's showing it to
you
i love how at the beginning you're like
yes
[Applause]
or like you know whatever something like
that when you start at the beginning
part i was like
oh yeah i've heard it that's the one
song i remember
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you